I made up a bigger test.
I made up a dictionary of hands that map from a hand to a set of words that I found.
The idea here is that this test is not so much proving that I've got the right answer,
because I don't know for sure that this is the right answers.
Rather, this is what we call a regression test, meaning as we change our program
we want to make sure that we haven't broken any of these--that we haven't made changes to our functions.
Even if I don't know this is exactly the right set, I want to know when I made a change,
have I changed the result here.
I'll be able to rerun this and say, have we done exactly the same thing.
I'll also be able to time the results of running these various hands
and see if we can make our function faster.
Here is my list of hands. I've got eight hands.
Then I did some further tests here.
I'm testing removing letters--got all those right.
Then I'm going through the hands, and I'm using my timedcall() function that we build last time.
That returnsin lapsed time and a set of results.
I make sure all the results are what I expected.
Then I return the time elapsed for finding all the words in those eight hands.
It turns out it takes half a second.
That kind of worries me. That doesn't sound very good.
Sure, if I was playing Scrabble with a friend and they reply in a half second, that'd be pretty good.
Much better than me, for example.
In this game here it says that I haven't replied to my friend Ken in 22 hours.
This is a lot better, but still, if we're going to be doing a lot of work
and trying to find the best possible play, half a second to evaluate eight hands--
that doesn't seem fast enough.
Why is find_words() so slow?
One thing is that it's got a lot of nested loops, and it always does all of them.
A lot of that is going to be wasteful.
For example, let's say the first two letters in the hand were z and q.
At the very start here w is z + q, and now I loop through all the other combinations
of all the other letters in the hand trying to find words that start with z + q,
but there aren't any words in the dictionary that start with zq.
As soon as I got here, I should be able to figure that out
and not do all of the rest of these nested loops.